네 안녕하세요 오늘은 작년에 상업용
부동산 거래가 제일 많았던 서초동에
[음악]
왔습니다
서초동이정재
많았어요 그래서 무려 거래 건수가
92건을 강남구 노현동 다 더
많았습니다 어 근데 여러분들이
서초동을 좀 보실 때 보통 다
교대역이랑 서초역 쪽만 생각을 하는데
강남역 1때도 포함이에요 그래서 거기
거래 건수도 같이 포함돼 있다 보니까
거래 건수가 이렇게 많다라고 보시면
될 거 같습니다 그리고 지금 제가
교대역 쪽에 많이 있는데 원래 여기
서초가 그 한강변 근처에 있어 가지고
여기가 약간 논밭이 있어요 그
서초동의 뜻이 서쪽에 있는 그 풀밭이
많은 곳이다라고 해가지고
서초라이브러리
1일대 상권입니다 강남역 자체가 워낙
유동인구가 많고 거기 1일 이용객
수가 무려 약 한 60만 명 정도
됩니다 좌측은
서초동이정재 것 같아요 좌측 같은
경우에는 거기 이면까지 다 이제 일반
상업지로 되어 있다 보니까 거기 안에
클럽들이 많이 있습니다 그리고 유흥
시설이 많이 발달되어 있다 보니까
여기 오른쪽 역삼동 보다는 왼쪽에
지금 서초동 부분이 더 활성화에 되
있다고 보시면 될 거 같습니다 왼쪽은
아무래도 일반 상업지가 보니까
건물들이 되게 좀 높게 올라와
있거든요 지금 뭐 임대 컨디션이라
그지 그리고 이제 건물 가격이라는
봤을 때 좌측 편이 조금 더 좋다라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다 거기 지금
강남역 1대 같은 경우에는 삼성 4옥
있잖아요 워낙 큰 오피스가 있어서
거기 일대의 상권들이 되게 좋거든요
강남역 상권이 서초동에서 제일
좋다라고 보시면 될 거 같고 그리고
두 번째로 여기 지금 교대역이랑 서초
역상이 있습니다 여기일 때는 아무래도
법원 근처다 보니까 그런 관련된
업종들이 좀 많이 들어와 있습니다
법률 사무소라고 법무사 사무소라고
그런 법률과 관련된 업종들이 좀 많이
밀집되어 있고 그리고 인근에 병원이
되게 많아요 흥남역 쪽도 병원이 많고
이쪽도 병원이 많습니다 그래서 지금
여기 건너편 같은 경우에는 임차인들이
대부분 다 병원이에요 배우 세대도
많이 밀집되어 있고 그리고 인근에
학교도 있다 보니까 젊은 사람들도 좀
많이 오는 곳이라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 그래서 요렇게 좀 상권을
정리하고 제가 매각 사례를 좀
준비했는데 여러분들한테 도움이 되실
만한 그런 매각 사례를 좀 소개해
드리려고 합니다
[음악]
가시죠네 그래서 첫 번째 매각 사례는
뒤에 보이는 저 건물입니다 지하
2층의 지상 10층 건물인데
2023년에 정말 놀랄 가격에 매각이
됐어요 돼지가 106평 인데 424억
매각이 됐습니다 평당 4억이 넘어요
그리고 연면적이 한 760명이 정도
되는데 지은지는 한 15년 정도 된
건물이고 연면적당 가격이 거의 한
5,600만 원 5천만 원 후반
때거든요 그래서 진짜 뭐 테 난로 급
정도의 가격 아니면 거의 도산대로 급
정도의 가격으로 매각이 된 건물입니다
그래서 아무래도 이제 역 바로 앞에
있다 보니까 위치는 좀 굉장히 좋긴
하지만 어 여기 일대에서는 그래도
최고가의 매각이 된 거 같아요 그리고
지금 오른쪽 건물이 일반 상업지고
왼쪽은 지금 3 종 이거든요 그래서
진짜 도로 하나에 따라서도 그 용도
지역이 다릅니다 일반 상업지가 가치가
좀 좋긴 하지만 그래도 여기 일대에서
높은 가격에 어 매각 됐다라고 보시면
될 거 같습니다 교대역 앞에도 평당
4억이라고 해서 어전 매각 사례를
준비했고요 그리고 두 번째 사례도
여러분들 진짜 아마 충격 받으실 수도
있는데 2022년도에 호환기 때
매입해 가지고 손해 본 사례입니다
어떻게 해서 손해가 봤는지 자세하게
설명드리도록 하겠습니다 가시죠
어 두 번째 사례는 지금 뒤에
보이는이 건물입니다 2022년도에
149억 매입을 했어요 진짜 대지가
100평 정도였는데 124억 매각을
했습니다 가격으로만 보자면 25억
정도 이제 손해가 봤는데 사실 이제
취득세란 기타 비용까지 생각하면 거의
30억 넘는 금액을 손해를 받습니다
자 아무래도 2022년도 하반기
때부터 빌딩 시장이 많이 안 좋아지기
시작했는데 상반기까지는 되게
괜찮았거든요 그때 이제 호환장치
비싸게 매입을 했습니다 인근 사례에
대비해서도 가격대가 꽤 컸고 물론
이제 여기가 교대역 바로이 면이고
위치적으로 되게 괜찮긴 하지만 대지
평당 1억 5천이면 좀 많이 비싼
편이 있긴 했거든요 근데 그때 사실
호환기 때는 건물들이 되게 비싸게 또
많이 팔렸어요 근데 이런 사례들이
생각보다 많이 있어요 그래서 이걸
보면서 저는 느끼는게 아 정말 시기가
되게 중요하구나 수익률이나 막 기타
사항들 막 이런 거 다 떠나서 가격이
오르는 시기랑 가격이 내려가는시기
그런 시기에 따라서 내가 가격이라는
이런게 진짜 천차 안별이 그나 이렇게
좀 생각을 많이 하게 됐습니다
그래서이 사례를 보면서음 많은 교훈을
주는 거 같아요 사실 20년도
21년도는 몰 사도 가격이 올랐거든요
비싸게 사도 비싸게 거래가 됐고
그리고 정말 매물이 많이 없었고요
근데 요즘에는 금액 협상도 되고 좋은
가격으로 매입할 수 있기 때문에
현금을 가지고 계신 분들은 매입하기
있는 좀 좋은 시기이지 않을까 근데
제가 항상 말씀드리는게 호환기 때는
뭘 사도 올랐기 때문에 위치 상관없이
막 다 샀어요 근데 요즘 같은
시기에는 정말 정말 꼼꼼하게 보고
정말 확실한 건물만 사야 됩니다
그렇지 않으면 공실이 나거나 나중에
매각이 어려워지는 그런 경우도
생깁니다 그런 부분을 좀 기억하셨으면
[음악]
좋겠습니다 어 서초동을 일단은
전체적인 전망을 좀 얘기하자면 법조
타운이 있기 때문에 기본적으로 오피스
수요도 좀 많이 있을 것 같고 그리고
터널 있는 쪽 공원 있는 쪽이 이제
개발될 계획이거든요 그래서 지금
mdm 해 거기 일대를 좀 개발하려고
하는 부분도 있어서 그거에 대한 좀
호재도 있는 거 같고 그리고 지금
경부 고속도로를 지하화 한다라는
얘기가 있긴 한데 이게 예산이 너무
많이 들긴 합니다 큰 예산에도
불구하고 그게 통과된다고 하면 거기일
때도 저는 되게 괜찮아질 거 같아요
경부고속도로 때문에 좀 이렇게 막혀
있는 느낌이 있긴 했거든요 근데 그게
이제 공원화가 되고 지하화가 된다라고
하면 거기 인근에도 좀 상권이
좋아지지 않을까 뭐 이렇게 예상을
하고 있습니다 어 그래서 서초동은 뭐
이런 개발 호재들이 많 많이 있어서
투자 가치는 충분히 있다라고
생각하지만 어
서초동이정재
투자 가치가 좋은 데가 어디야라고
하면은 저기 강남역 일대입니다 그쪽
일대가 그래도 저는 투자 가치가 제일
높다라고 생각하기 때문에 개인적인
생각이니까 여러분들 투자하시는는데 좀
도움이 되셨으면 좋겠습니다 그리고
지금 강남역 거기 삼성 사업 인근
같은 경우에는 거기 회사원들 연봉이
되게 높거든요 웬만한 분들 다 이제
억대 연봉 이상 분들이 많아서 거기
단가가 되게 높습니다 그래서 단가가
높다 보니까 임대료도 좀 되게 높게
책정이 돼 있고 그래서 수익성
측면에서도 되게 괜찮은 거 같아요
아무래도 법조타운이 있는데 그 어르신
분들이 많다 보니까 여기 교대역 인금
같은 경우에는 어 젊은 사람들이 물론
이제 교대나 여기 인근에 학원이
많아서 좀 많이 오긴 하지만 젊은
사람들이 올만한 포인트 이런 거는
많이 없는 거 같긴 해요 교대역 많이
나보신 분들은 알겠지만 젊은 사람들은
강남역으로 좀 많이 가는 거 같기도
합니다 거기 가면은 좀 젊은 사람들이
좋아할 만한 그런 업종들이 그지
가게라는 그런 것들이 많기 때문에
교대지점 역이라는 이쪽 인근에 뭔가
젊은 사람들이 올 만한 그런 부분을
좀 만들면 좀 더 좋지 않을까네
이렇게 생각을 하고요 그리고 예술대
전당은 저는 진짜 엄청나게 좋다라고
생각하거든요 그래서 앞으로 이렇게
문화적 수요를 할 사람들은 더 많아질
것 같아요 서울시뿐만 아니에
우리나라에 공연을 할 수 있고 엄청난
건축물에 엄청난 공간 엄청난 문화
시설을 할 수 있는 시설이 많이 없기
때문에 이쪽 일대 큰 호재라고
생각하기 때문에이 부분을 좀 잘
살려서 하면 좋지 않을까 개인적으로
생각하고 있습니다네 그리고 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요 빌딩은 역시 필사나
[음악]